[Musique]
ces camps ne sont pas acceptables à la
fois pour les gens qui s'y retrouvent
des situations de misère il faut le dire
également des situations de délinquance
qui posent de véritables difficultés aux
riverains
il est absolument nécessaire que ces
camps puissent être traitées et surtout
ne pas se reconstituer cette opération
bien évidemment se fait dans le cadre
des demandes du ministre de l'intérieur
et d'une vision qui consiste avant tout
par humanité à faire en sorte que les
personnes en situation régulière
les personnes qui ont droit puisse
trouver une mise à l'abri nécessaire les
personnes en situation irrégulière n'ont
pas vocation à rester sur le territoire
national comme l'a rappelé plusieurs
fois le ministre de l'intérieur
[Musique]
à
en